Alright, now we can actually dive in and
give a definition for PAC-learnable. So, a concept class,
C, is PAC-learnable by some learning algorithm, L, using
its own representation of hypothesis, H, if and only
if that learner will, with high probability, at least
1 minus Delta, ouput a hypothesis h, little h,
from its set of hypothesis. That has error less
than or equal to epsilon, so it's very accurate.
And it needs to be the case that the time that it takes
to do this. And the number of samples that it needs draws from
this distribution D is relatively small. In fact, bounded by polynomial in one
over epsilon, one over delta and the size of the hypothesis space n.
>> Okay, so in other words you're saying something is
PAC-learnable if you can learn to get low error, at least
with some high confidence you can be fairly confident that you will have
a low error in time that's sort of polynomial in all the parameters.
>> Exactly, and you can see here that this, this epsilon and delta
actually giving us a lot of wiggle room, if you really want to
have perfect error. Or perfect certainty. Then these things go to infinity. So,
you just, you need, you need to look at all the possible data.
>> Mm.
>> So, yeah this is really going to only give us partial guarantees.
>>
Okay. Sure. Okay, I think I understand that. .